- Uncomfortably overrated.
Welcome to another episode
of Underrated Overrated
with me, Garyvee.
(fun music)
First, before I go into this episode,
thank you so much to everybody
that lost their mind for this show.
I think we've got several
episodes we're about to film.
DRock, take it away.
- [DRock] Portuguese wine.
- Portuguese wine.
Underrated. Wildly underrated.
I'm telling you right now, under 20 bucks,
maybe the best in the world.
- [DRock] Billie Eilish.
- Billie Eilish. Underrated.
I think if you think
about the next ten years,
she's got more in the can.
- [DRock] Hollywood.
- Wildly overrated.
I think Hollywood is being disrupted,
but the talent there is incredible
and it has been America's
ultimate weapon for 80 years,
but I'm still gonna go with
overrated at this moment.
- [DRock] Triller.
- Triller.
Properly rated.
Winning in certain areas,
but still has a lot to go.
You can't just be an alternative
to government regulation,
but I believe there might
be some innovation there.
- [DRock] Pokémon.
- Pokémon. Underrated.
The cards are underrated,
the IP is underrated.
Go look up the value of
Pokémon's IP versus Star Wars.
- [DRock] Twitter Fleets.
- Twitter Fleets. Overrated.
I think that it's a
okay feature on Twitter,
I just-- right at this second,
it's only a couple weeks in,
but I'm gonna go with slightly overrated.
- [DRock] King Bach.
- King Bach. Wildly underrated.
I'll do it right here on the show,
King Bach will be one of the
biggest actors in Hollywood
ten years from the filming of this.
One of the ten, fifteen
biggest actors in Hollywood.
- [DRock] James Charles.
- Properly rated.
Has a cult-like following,
humongous following,
still not known by a
lot of the mainstream.
Has had some flub-ubs,
but is going through it,
young person, I think properly
rated, which is pretty solid.
- [DRock] Day trading.
- Day trading is the most
underrated thing in the world.
Being fast and executing works.
It works on Wall Street, it
really works in marketing.
Wildly underrated, maybe the most
underrated thing we've done this show.
Day trading attention is my religion.
- [DRock] Drake.
- Drake?
That's a good one. I would
say Drake is underrated.
I think Drake's underrated
because, I think he's
wildly rated, but I think people like
to hate when someone's at the top,
and if you just think about the output
of music and cultural relevance--
I also think he has a humility
card that is underrated.
I think Drake is underrated.
- [DRock] Injury reserve.
(laughing)
- In sports, injury reserve--
I would say injury reserve
is-- I don't even know
where to go with this.
Injury reserve is overrated just 'cause
I want something to be overrated.
- [DRock] Kanye West's
entrepreneurial career.
- Properly rated. I'll tell you why.
I think a lot of people
grossly underrate him.
Because he's done a bunch of stuff
and I fully expect his
impact on Gap to matter.
I think some people overrate him
'cause they've got him on Jesus status
and I'd like to see a couple more things
out of him to go there.
I think Kanye is properly rated.
- [DRock] Hype House.
- Hype House is overrated.
We're talking about all of them, right?
It's fun, I like 'em,
but I think there's a lot
of underlining anxiety and muckery
that isn't talked about enough.
And I just, I don't think a lot
of people are gonna leave Hype House
as like, awesomely better off.
I'm not hating, but I
think they're overrated.
I think there's a lot of
people fifteen years old
right now watching and
dying to one day live
in a Hype House, and I don't think
that they need it as much as they think.
- [DRock] NBA YoungBoy.
- YoungBoy. Never Broke Again.
I think he is a underrated energy.
If you look under
twenty-year-old fan bases,
there might not be a bigger one out there,
and so, you know, he's got a lot going on,
I'd love to chop it up
with that kid one day.
- [DRock] Pirate Bay.
- Parrot Bay? The place
in Turks and Caicos?
- [DRock] No where you rip
off the software and all that.
- Oh, Pirate Bay.
Pirate Bay is grossly underrated.
I think pirating and-- you know,
I have so many of my
books ripped off there,
I think it's an important part of society.
I think it's like yin to the yang
that is mainstream society.
I will go with Pirate
Bay being underrated.
- [DRock] The verification badges.
- Uncomfortably overrated.
Being verified has become
this crazy status symbol
that people clout on,
and most people use it as
a douche bag energy and I hate it.
Like, that blue check, that verification
giving people clout is not good.
It's high school, it's bad. I'm not a fan.
- [DRock] Vsco.
- I'm gonna go with vsco being
overrated, believe it or not.
I think it's wildly
important to a certain demo,
I think it's a good app.
But it's been the same
thing for four years now.
Which is like another
place for young females
to play it out, and I think
they haven't innovated enough.
I think vsco four years ago had the chance
with seven smart moves, innovation M&A,
to be a major player, maybe even
the number one social network.
So I would go with vsco being overrated.
- [DRock] LinkedIn.
- LinkedIn is wildly underrated,
I've been boring for 24 months,
pounding the shit out of all of you,
to produce content on it.
Under priced attention,
day trading attention,
and you can post anything on there.
"Teeny bop" influencers can
build audience on LinkedIn.
- [DRock] Pumpkin pie.
- Pumpkin pie is...
something I don't like
as much as I used to.
But I'm gonna go with overrated
'cause I think pumpkin spice lattes
have probably grown pumpkin pie's status.
And pumpkin pie is delish.
I'm about that pumpkin pie.
But I'm still gonna go slightly overrated.
- [DRock] Sweet potatoes.
- Sweet potatoes are
also slightly overrated
'cause I think sweet potato fries
have become a huge game and I think--
yeah, I'm gonna go with
slightly overrated.
- [DRock] Dogs.
- You guys are fuckfaces.
Goddammit.
I promised myself to
always give my real answer.
I think dogs are overrated.
I love-- I don't love...
Dogs are great, and I think that people
love animals more than humans at scale,
in a way that I think is not right,
and it's only because animals
don't communicate the
same way that humans do,
and most people are insecure
and they use animals
as an excuse for not doing
good behavior to other humans.
I think dogs are overrated.
And I know I'm gonna get blasted.
Doesn't mean they're bad,
I think they're overrated.
(exasperated groan)
You guys literally just gave
me 48 hours of headaches.
Alright.
- [DRock] Hashtags.
- Underrated.
Following hashtags,
understanding why hashtags work,
is one of the great
post-creative strategies,
if you don't understand it, Google it.
It's one of the great things
to understand in society.
It is a currency of understanding
the current pulse of thinking.
Big fan of hashtags,
grossly underestimated.
- [DRock] Black Friday sales.
- Black Friday sales are now overrated,
they're lame, they're not
innovating, they're boring.
You're almost getting those
same deals all the time.
- [DRock] Christmas.
- Christmas is properly rated.
- [DRock] PlayStation 5.
- PlayStation 5 is properly rated.
- [DRock] Yu-Gi-Oh! cards.
- Yu-Gi-Oh! cards are underrated.
They still have 20 to
100 percent value uptick
in the youngest crew
underneath the Pokémon crew,
those late 20's characters are gonna make
Yu-Gi-Oh! cards really pop in a decade.
In 15 years, a lot of 27-year-olds
are gonna have a lot more money
and Yu-Gi-Oh! cards are
gonna be wildly under priced
today comparative to what
they will be in 15 years.
- [DRock] Jasiah the rapper.
- Ooh, nice.
Jasiah the rapper, wildly underrated.
- [DRock] Facebook.
- Facebook is underrated.
People shit on Facebook at scale today.
It is still one of the
most significant platforms,
it dominates 50 to
100-year-olds' attention,
its platform has
over-indexed in its ability
to change Facebook Marketplace, groups.
Facebook is underrated.
I also predict that Facebook in 40 years
will have a reboot nostalgia brand change,
and will be some form of
the newest social network
after being kind of dormant for awhile.
Underrated.
- [DRock] Final one. Taco Bell.
- Taco Bell is overrated.
I think it's an incredible brand,
I'm a big fan, I love their marketing.
But if I'm being honest, I'm shooting it--
that's what I'm doing here.
It's feeling a little stale.
I think it needs to do some action.
That was Overrated
Underrated with Garyvee.
Please tune into the next episode.
(fun music)